In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinak Sarion for April 30, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Ignatius Briancianinov, Bishop of Stavropol.
Our Holy Father Ignatius was born in the year 1807 in the province of Vologda, in the bosom
of a family of the ancient Russian nobility.
He was given the name Dmitri at his baptism, gifted with exceptional intelligence and a noble
enforceable character.
He evaded the ascendancy that he could have exercised over the other children in order
to withdraw alone into nature, to pray there and slowly pronounce the words he was addressing
to God.
He loved going to church and reading the gospel and found his delights in the lives of the
saints.
He wrote later, I had my God, no one to whom to open my heart.
But thy peaman, Cisoes and macadios, produced a wonderful impression on me.
My thoughts often soared Godward when I prayed and read, and little by little peace and tranquility
came into my soul.
At the age of 15, an inexpressible silence rained in my soul and my heart, but I did not understand
it.
I thought it was like that for everyone.
After an excellent education at home, he entered the College of the Engineer Corps in St.
Petersburg, where he studied with such brilliant results that he attracted the attention of Grand
Duke Nicholas, the future emperor Nicholas I, who made him one of his proto-Jays.
The secular life that was offered to him in this capital that was striving to open up to
the West left his soul with a sense of emptiness.
Science and philosophy were incapable of satisfying his spiritual hunger, and it was with tears
that he implored God not to abandon him in error and despair.
In company with a friend Michael, he consecrated his time to prayer, and the reading of the
Church Fathers, their holiness, he wrote, is the guarantee of their exactitude.
The reading of the Fathers has taught me that this earthly life must be consecrated to
preparing ourselves for eternity, like a vestibule leading into a magnificent royal palace.
Permiated by these thoughts and convinced that the perfection of Christianity is to be found
in monasticism, monks being light for their brethren who live in the world.
He began to maintain a secret contact with the Fathers of the monastery of St. Alexander
Nevsky, who astonished at his spiritual maturity, encouraged him to pursue his researches in spite
of the opposition of his family and the college authorities.
In the year 1826, a serious illness made him prepare for the possibility of death, devoting
himself even more greatly to prayer and reading.
Having recovered his health, he made the acquaintance of Father Leonid, the heir of the tradition
of St. Paesius, Paesius Velicicovsky, and the future studets of the monastery of
Optina.
In spite of all these obstacles, he obeyed the irresistible call of his conscience, and
although he had been promoted an officer, resigned when he was taken ill again and entered
the monastery of St. Alexander in Svir as a novice under the spiritual direction of Father
Leonid.
As signed to the kitchen, he served with humility and self-abnigation under the orders
of one of his father's old serfs.
Several times, when he was bowing reverently to the brethren, he was as though prostrated
by violent incursions of divine grace which left him in a state above nature for entire days.
His absolute obedience made him respected by all the monks, and he never neglected the
opportunity to reveal all his thoughts to his spiritual father, who formed him in the
most authentic monastic tradition that had become so rare at that time.
In the year 1828, he succeeded the studets at the Hermitage of Brociansk, and then at Optina,
and went to stay in other monasteries with Michael, his companion in Askecies, ever since
military college.
One of the fathers whom he met said these words to him, but remained deeply imprinted in him.
If one single day passes on which I do not mourn for myself, as for one who is moving towards
destruction, I consider myself to have been struck by spiritual blindness.
Pretending that his mother was ill, his father summoned him home, hoping to protect him from
a monastic influence, but his efforts were in vain, and in the year 1830, the two nobly-born
novices left for the monastery of St. Cyril, where Dimitri fell gravely ill.
Once restored to health, he was transferred monk by the bishop of Vologda, under the name
of Ignatius, and was shortly afterwards ordained deacon and priest.
He was then appointed superior of the monastery of Lopov in the same diocese of Vologda,
which was in total disrepair.
In spite of his youth and precarious health, the new abbot immediately showed great qualities
as an administrator and a spiritual father.
The number of monks grew, the buildings where restored and the monastic life was able to
develop with regularity, and in good order.
Ignatius was again attacked by a cruel illness because of the damp and unhealthy climate and
the situation of the monastery in the middle of the marshes, and he had to transfer to another
monastery in the diocese of Moscow.
As soon as the emperor heard what had happened to his protégé, he made him an archimandrite
and abbot of the monastery of St. Sirgeus near St. Petersburg, with the task of transforming
it into a model monastic community which guests of the court could visit.
The geographical situation of this monastery, its climate, the dilapidated state of the
buildings, the proximity of the capital, and its inevitable contact with the court, constituted
enormous obstacles to all that the saint had learned in his reading of the Holy Fathers
about the conditions necessary to the monastic life.
He put however all his trust in providence, and very soon had the buildings restored and
established strict senobidic discipline and the dignified observance of all the monastic
offices.
He succeeded so well in this that the flow of pilgrims increased and brought many candidates
for the monastic life.
In spite of the successive illnesses that used up the last strength of a health already
debilitated and wore him out, Ignatius showed remarkable qualities in the spiritual direction
of his monks.
Full of patience and tolerance towards human weakness, he knew how to be a father to each
of them, and gave his community great spiritual vitality.
He especially underlined the importance of the revealing of all thoughts to the spiritual
father, and the interior battle using the weapons of watchfulness, sobriety, and the Jesus
prayer.
Four years later, he was appointed the inspector of all the monasteries in the St. Petersburg
diocese, and his influence was thenceforth felt by many of the young people, but it also
made him many enemies.
Some of the clergy, jealous of his appointment to such great responsibilities, and some of
the members of high society, offended by the reproaches that he had addressed to the moral
laxness that was rife in their circles, obstinately sought to denigrate his efforts, and bring them
to not.
In the midst of these trials, he nonetheless never ceased giving thanks to God, and wrote
in his lamentations, it is in these trials that the merciful Lord has vouchsaved to me
to know this joy and peace of soul that words cannot express.
It is in them that he has allowed me to taste the love and spiritual blessings at the
very hour at which I encountered my enemy, who was after my life, and the face of the enemy
became in my eyes like that of a bright angel.
What a blessing it is to be a victim as Jesus was, or rather what a blessing to be crucified
beside the Savior as the good thief was, and to say, for us indeed justly, Lord, remember
me when thou comest into thy kingdom.
When he was put to similar tests, he withdrew to his cell to give himself to prayer, bathed
in tears, until the moment that divine consolation came to fill him with ineffable joy.
The word of God sprang up of itself in his heart, and he then gave himself under its dictation
to the writing of his spiritual works.
After a long moment when this state had left him, he left his room with a radiant and
extraordinarily serene face.
In the year 1847, physically exhausted, he was temporarily relieved of his duties, and
withdrew to the monastery of Nicholas Baba Yevo in the Kostroma province near Volga.
He made use of this period of tranquility and silence to write a great many letters of
spiritual direction, and continue his writing, which was especially concentrated on the Jesus
prayer.
Lucid and aware of the numerous dangers of delusion that lies in weight in this spiritual activity,
for beginners without an authorized guide, he insists above all on sincere repentance
and humility manifested by tears, which alone can protect us from delusion, stemming
from self-satisfaction and pride.
He advises them not to follow too quickly the methods used by the fathers for fixing the
mind in the heart, and insistently underlines that it is moral conduct guided by the obedience
of the evangelical commandments that leads to the purification of our passions and prepares
our heart to be a vessel worthy to receive when God wills it the holy chrism of the prayer
of the heart.
He therefore recommends that the beginner give himself to the prayer of repentance, fixing
his attention on the words of the Jesus prayer, repeated at first in an undertone, and then
little by little, inner-ly.
Guarding thus the attention, the mind will then turn progressively in sympathy with the spirit
called the heart by the fathers.
The place of the heart will, by the grace of God, reveal itself to us, and our whole being
will then be drawn into an inconceivable momentum towards true contemplation, to spiritual delights
free from delusion and the joy of the vision of the living God.
But this free gift of divine grace, this love of God poured into the soul that attains
the height of virtue, will ever remain closed to those whose desire is to lay hold of it
at the wrong time, impudently and rashly.
Being again taken up his duties at St. Sergius after a stay at Optina, where he could not
remain in spite of his desire for withdrawal, he was consecrated Bishop of Stavropol in
the year 1857.
This was an area in the Caucasus and the Black Sea, recently conquered by the Russians, and
with a population that was still hostile.
And small, obedient to the decrees of providence, used all his strength, traveling around his
huge diocese, and made a great contribution to the religious education of the young.
In the year 1861, a further illness definitively ruined his health, and he received permission
to retire to the monastery of St. Nicholas Baba Yevole, together with a small group of his
spiritual sons.
Interested with the administration of this monastery that had been left to decay, he
organized it, and had a new church built.
In addition to his writing and the direction of the monks, the number of which increased,
he received the local peasants who came to consult him about all sorts of matters, becoming
for them a physician of both soul and body.
It is there that he entered into rest in peace on the 30th of April, in the year 1867, leaving
behind him a rich spiritual heritage that has remained one of the surest guides in the
seeking of God, for all who desire today to follow the authentic tradition of the Holy
Fathers.
After his blessed death, St. Ignatius appeared at the heart of a dazzling light to one of
his spiritual sons who was the prey of attacks by the demons, and said to him, all I have
written in my books is the truth.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.